>> RONI, THANK YOU SO MUCH .
THANK YOU FOR TALKING TO US.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU ARE BRAVE.
I KNOW.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>>> ALSO TONIGHT, VIRAL VIDEOS
ABOUT THE WAR HAVING HUGE IMPACT
. THEY ARE COMPLETELY FAKE BUT
HAVING DIRE CONSEQUENCES.
>> Reporter: WHEN VIDEO SHOWS A
ROCKET REPORTEDLY FIRED BY HAMAS
AND OTHER VIDEO CLAIMS TO SHOW
ISRAELI JETS BOMBING GAZA
APPEARED NEITHER IS REAL THIS
VIDEO IS FOOTAGE FROM A
VIDEOGAME AND THIS IS VIDEO OF
SOCCER CELEBRATIONS IN ALGERIA.
IT IS PART OF THE TIDAL WAVE OF
VIRAL MISINFORMATION AND
DISINFORMATION CIRCULATING
AROUND THE ISRAEL AND HAMAS
CONFLICT.
WORKS WITH ONLINE INTELLIGENCE
SERVICE AND MONITORING
MISINFORMATION LIKE THIS, FAKE
BBC NEWS REPORT THAT FALSELY
CLAIMED UKRAINE PROVIDED
WEAPONS TO HAMAS.
THIS IS RELATIVELY
SOPHISTICATED STUFF, IT HAS THE
SAME GRAPHICS AS THE BBC NEWS
WOULD HAVE.
>> RIGHT.
I THINK WHAT HAPPENED OVER
RECENT YEARS, IT BECOMES VERY
EASY AND AFFORDABLE TO MIMIC
THOSE GRAPHICS VISUALIZATIONS.
>> Reporter: RESPONSE TO PAUL'S
NEWS REPORT, BBC TOLD CNN IN A
STATEMENT, WORLD OF INCREASING
DISINFORMATION, WE URGE EVERYONE
TO ENSURE THEY ARE GETTING
INFORMATION FROM A TRUSTED
SOURCE.
HOURS AFTER THE HAMAS ATTACK
BEGAN ON SATURDAY, THIS BEGAN
CIRCULATING ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
FAKE WHITE HOUSE MEMO FALSELY
CLAIMING THE U.S. WAS SENDING
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN NEW AID
TO ISRAEL. THIS IS LIKE OLD
SCHOOL DISINFORMATION, FAKE
WHITE HOUSE DOCUMENT CIRCULATED
PRETTY WIDELY ONLINE.
>> RIGHT. I DO WANT TO POINT
OUT IT IS OLD-SCHOOL TACTIC WE
HAVE SEEN MULTIPLE YEARS BY NOW.
WITH THE CURRENT TOOLS, YOU CAN
ALSO CREATE IT VERY QUICKLY AND
MAKE IT.
>> NEW INFORMATION EVERY SECOND
AND EVERY MINUTE AND EVERY HOUR
AND A LOT OF ROOM FOR ERROR AS
THINGS DEVELOP ON THE GROUND.
>> Reporter: TRACKS
DISINFORMATION WITH ATLANTIC
COUNCIL DIGITAL FORENSIC
RESEARCH LAB.
>> IT IS HYPER CONNECTED,
ISRAEL IS VERY CONNECTED
COUNTRY SO WE CAN SEE ENORMOUS
AMOUNT OF MISLEADING CONTENT
COMING OUT OF THIS CONFLICT AS
THE WORLD'S EYES ARE WATCHING.
>> Reporter: TWITTER KNOWN AS X
IS A MAJOR SOURCE OF
MISINFORMATION PARTLY BECAUSE
OF THE CHANGES ELON MUSK MADE
TO THE PLATFORM SINCE HE TOOK
OVER INCLUDING LAYING OFF KEY
EMPLOYEES.
ON THURSDAY, EUROPEAN
COMMISSION ANNOUNCED IT WAS
OPENING INVESTIGATION INTO
DISINFORMATION ON X ABOUT THE
ISRAELI HAMAS CONFLICT.
>> ANOTHER COMPONENT BECAUSE
SEVERAL PLATFORMS SCALED-BACK
MODERATION, IT IS MUCH EASIER
TO SPREAD RUMORS,
UNSUBSTANTIATED RUMORS, FALSE
INFORMATION VERY QUICK.
>> Reporter: THIS ISN'T JUST
INFORMATION WAR, IT IS A REAL
WAR AND FALSE INFORMATION CAN
BE FATAL
>> DISINFORMATION IS
EXTRAORDINARILY HARMFUL,
PUTTING FOLKS LIVES AT RISK.
>> Reporter: TWITTER, X SA